[Música]
hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo los
saluda juliet riaño
[Música]
los más de 40 años de guerra en
afganistán dejan en el exilio a miles de
personas y el retorno hace un año de los
talibanes al poder produjo un nuevo
éxodo donde los países vecinos son los
principales receptores más de 250.000
afganos se refugiaron en pakistán desde
agosto de 2021 una comunidad extranjera
que es mantenida al margen de la
sociedad ya que las autoridades
paquistaníes buscan evitar que se
establezcan a largo plazo en el corazón
de islamabad cientos de refugiados
permanecen en campamentos improvisados y
piden la ayuda de la comunidad
internacional para obtener asilo en
europa o en eeuu está su historia
en el corazón de islamabad más de 700
familias de refugiados afganos viven en
la calle huyeron de afganistán después
de que los talibanes tomaran el poder en
agosto del año pasado esta familia llegó
a pakistán hace cinco meses y no puede
permitirse alquilar una casa es difícil
para nosotros vivimos en la carretera
hay polvo y suciedad por todas partes
hay humedad vivimos en condiciones
terribles estamos aquí día y noche
incluso cuando llueve mis hijos están
creciendo en este lugar necesitan ser
educados deberían estar en la escuela no
es nuestra culpa que nuestro país esté
en esta situación que debemos hacer
ahora nacimos solo para morir en esta
tienda vecina los niños sufren
diferentes enfermedades de piel causadas
por las condiciones de vida
antihigiénicas
combina las piernas de mi hija están
llenas de manchas rojas y forúnculos los
tiene por todo el cuerpo mi otra hija
los tiene incluso en la cabeza llevamos
ocho meses viviendo aquí y no hay nadie
que nos ayude en este vídeo vemos el
agua obtiene de este lado y también de
aquí y todos los niños están acurrucados
bajo una manta en un lado estas imágenes
tomadas por un refugiado afgano muestran
la situación durante la temporada de
monzones casi todos los días el
campamento improvisado se inundaba por
la lluvia sin embargo estos refugiados
se niegan a abandonar la capital y
esperan que las embajadas extranjeras en
islamabad escuchen su petición de ayuda
y pedimos ayuda a la comunidad
internacional a la unión europea y
especialmente a los países que dicen
conceder asilo a los refugiados
para arcarde deben ayudarnos escapamos
de un reino de terror y crueldad
el futuro de estos refugiados afganos
parece sombrío en pakistán obtener el
estatus de refugiado en el país es casi
imposible
desde que los talibanes regresaron al
poder las mujeres fueron perseguidas y
sus derechos arrebatados por lo que
muchos buscaron protección lejos de
afganistán hasta francia llegaron
algunas y allí intentan rehacer su vida
pero esperan volver algún día a su país
cuando el gobierno talibán ya no esté al
mando
el 15 de agosto de 2021 cuando los
talibanes tomaron kabul los estudios de
fatma quedaron interrumpidos a sus 23
años este estudiante de medicina afgana
tuvo que volver a empezar ahora recibe
clases en la oficina de inmigración e
integración de francia para mejorar su
nivel de francés y poder continuar sus
estudios en el pasado los talibanes
prohibieron la entrada de las mujeres a
las universidades y creo que todos los
países especialmente afganistán
necesitan buenos médicos mujeres médicas
que ayuden a otras mujeres y niñas
con la ayuda de su hermana que ya vivía
en francia logró salir de afganistán en
8 días a bordo de un avión francés vi a
abu dhabi
pero una vez en suelo francés le
esperaba un nuevo reto
ahora que vivo en francia es importante
que hable francés 11
meses para estudiar medicina a trabajar
y comunicarme
ok
de julio y después trabajará para
conseguir helados y el b1 para lograr su
objetivo
fatma piensa a menudo que su vida cambió
para siempre
nunca esperé que los talibanes pudieran
ocupar también kabul
ese 15 de agosto de 2021 llegó a su
universidad tenía que presentar un
examen
los plazos salen todo el lugar estaba en
silencio
uno de mis profesores me dijo fuck me
tienes que volver a casa los talibanes
capturaron cabos
puse a llorar porque como era posible
era el fin de mi sueño
pero a fatma no fue a la única que la
vida le cambió muchas otras estudiantes
también huyeron a francia entre ellas
soraya que representará a su país en
balonmano
en abril de 2021 perdió una compañera de
equipo nuria tavex fue asesinada en su
propia casa y tras la caída de la
capital recibieron una advertencia del
talibán si no dejaban de jugar se
enfrentarían a duros castigos así que
soraya también huyó
y cambiar de país es difícil sobre todo
cuando estás solo pero ahora tengo
muchas amigas como fardín a fátima y
sumayah y espero que al estar aquí
podamos hablar en favor de las mujeres
que se quedaron en afganistán bajo el
régimen talibán y hacer que sus voces se
escuchen en todo el mundo
a la izquierda fardín a médica en
afganistán somalia a la derecha era una
joven diputada a pesar de todo lo que
han pasado estas mujeres están decididas
el deseo de farmer es volver algún día a
su país libre del dominio talibán hablar
francés con fluidez y ser una doctora
cualificada de los más de 89 millones de
desplazados forzosos en todo el mundo
reportados en 2021 por acnur la mayoría
provienen sólo de cinco países uno de
ellos es afganistán 2,7 millones de
afganos huyeron y se desplazaron
internamente o fuera de sus fronteras
hasta que inmigrantes de france 24 los
invitamos a comentar en nuestras redes
sociales con el hashtag migrantes f24
sigan con más información en france 24 y
france 24 puntocom
[Música]